[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to Coffee with a Googler.
Today I'm meeting
with Alex Danilo
to talk about web standards
and why they're so important.
ALEX DANILO: So
[? LoMo, ?] so tell
me, with all these
interviews and stuff,
have you actually
learned anything useful?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Have I
Wow.
Certainly I've learned how
hard it can be in a studio.
No, but seriously.
It's been really fun
to chat with a lot
of different and various
Googlers from around the world,
and from different
things that they do.
Like, I had Josh Gordon on
for one episode where we
spoke about machine learning.
And machine learning
is something
that I've been trying
to study, and having
a lot of trouble with.
ALEX DANILO: It's complicated.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's
really complicated.
And my math days are
like 20 years behind me.
And one of the things
that Josh spoke about
is, like, how he's teaching
machine learning, and trying
not to be so mathy about it.
And that really helped.
And we had Ankur Kotwal
on a recent episode.
And he was talking a lot about
Google Maps and Santa Tracker,
and a lot of behind the scenes
of Santa Tracker and the stuff
that he built. And I
learned how important it is
to have a good project manager.
You'll have to watch the episode
to see what we mean about that.
ALEX DANILO: Cool,
I'll watch it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And I was
actually thinking about you
the other day when
I read this quote.
And it was-- I'm paraphrasing,
I may have it wrong.
But it was something
along the lines of,
like, the great
thing about standards
is that there are so many
of them to choose from.
And I know you're
working on standards.
Was that an Andrew
Tanenbaum quote?
ALEX DANILO: It was.
That was his quote.
Yeah, definitely.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now
you're working on standards,
and you're working
on web standards
in particular for Google.
And it's like, well, what's
the status of the web today?
How are things
going with the web,
and how are things
going with standards?
ALEX DANILO: Well,
that's a great question.
There's a lot of
activity in standards.
I mean, there are
multiple groups.
There are multiple working
groups, as you know.
Personally, I'm working on the
HTML standard at the moment.
So I'm helping edit the spec
with a bunch of colleagues
from other companies.
And the way I kind of
view it is standards
are really important, because
without standards, things
don't work right.
If I write a web page and I
just bash the markup together,
it might work in
my browser, but it
won't work in other browsers.
And the way it works
across browsers
is through standards, right?
So that the browsers
implement the same thing.
And if I implement my page
adhering to the standards,
it will work everywhere, right?
LAURENCE MORONEY: And it's
important to get things working
the same way everywhere, right?
I remember the old story about--
wasn't it like a Mars mission?
Where the Europeans
measured it in metric,
and we measured it in imperial.
And instead of
landing, it went splat.
ALEX DANILO: Slammed
in the planet.
All over.
Same thing happened
quite a long time
ago with the Fortran
program as well.
Where it was like people
decided to use Fortran for one
of the space probes in NASA.
And somebody put a comma
where there should have been
a full stop, or vice versa.
The probe went
flying off into space
because it had a variable
that wasn't being used.
It was just [INAUDIBLE].
Now the space program
doesn't use Fortran anymore.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Is that why?
ALEX DANILO: Well,
probably that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So what
have they switched to?
ALEX DANILO: Most likely Ada.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
ALEX DANILO: That is a
military standard, in fact.
So standards are important from
a lot of different aspects.
Just for developers, you
kind of think, yeah, great.
Why have them?
Andrew Tanenbaum's right.
There's a zillion
of them out there.
But a perfect example is in
the old days of the railroad,
back in the 1800s
or whatever it was,
there were competing companies
building their own railroad
tracks, but they were
different widths.
So you get to the
state border, and you
wouldn't be able to
continue with the train
because they didn't
have a standard gauge.
Hence, they brought
in a standard gauge.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I see.
ALEX DANILO: So it's
the same with the web.
We define a set of standards.
Every browser vendor
builds those standards
into their browser.
So when I build
for the standard,
I can expect it to
work everywhere.
And if it doesn't, it's a bug.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Right, so you don't
want to be that
train that fits one
railroad, but not the other.
ALEX DANILO: Exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So what
exactly does your role entail?
What are you doing?
ALEX DANILO: What we're
doing-- well, what I'm doing
is basically working with
a bunch of the other folks
in the HTML group.
And we collate all the changes
that people submit to us.
Like the working
group works together,
but it's an open
development process.
Like for example, if
you're a web developer
and you come up with
some brilliant idea
that you want in the spec,
you can talk about it.
You can bring it to what we call
the web incubation community
group.
You can work on the
kind of idea there.
Develop it.
And then if becomes
kind of stable,
we'll pull it into
the standards.
So as editors, it's our
job to write the words,
put it into the spec,
make sure it's testable,
and it will go
through the process
and eventually become
a real browser feature.
LAURENCE MORONEY: HTML5 was
the most recent big spec
that everybody's
been hearing about.
What's next?
ALEX DANILO: Well the
next is 5.1, which
I'm working on at the moment.
And 5.1 is kind of interesting.
It's a refinement
of 5.0 in many ways.
There are a number
of new things,
and there are a number
of things being dropped.
One good example of a
feature that's being dropped
is called request autocomplete.
So that was a feature for
payments on the web, which
was great on mobile devices.
And it shipped in
Chrome, so it's
shipped to stable browsers.
However, the uptake by the
community and developers
has been really low.
So we're like, well, other
browsers aren't doing it.
This is not a feature we would
want developers to try and use,
because it's just not
prevalent everywhere.
So we're pulling it.
So 5.1 will actually make
us a bit closer to reality.
That's kind of a
big aim for 5.1.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
Now given that we're moving
more and more mobile,
and we're moving more and
more towards apps instead
of desktops with browsers,
and our internet information
access is coming through
apps, what impact
is that having on standards?
Are standards becoming
less important?
ALEX DANILO: I
think standards are
important for different reasons.
Like the app thing is
important in its own right.
But we've kind of
seen a huge wave
of adoption of the app stores,
and the all this sort of thing
in Google Play, etc.
However, the way I look at
as a more web-focused person
is that apps are great.
Like, I've written apps myself.
But there are something like 2
million-odd apps in the store.
So if I want to find
something, the discovery
is really, really
difficult, right?
The story of discoverability
in apps is terrible.
And I can only install a
few on my phone, right?
You're really lucky
to install 100.
And so, from the point
of view of usability,
I'd only install apps that
I really, really need,
that I will use every day.
If you switch back to kind of
the web focus, with the web,
you can basically go to
this site and that site.
In fact, you can go
to millions of sites
without installing
anything on your phone.
You just go through the browser.
So the beauty of that is
that I can go-- well today,
I'm going to go to this
shopping store, use their site,
buy their stuff.
And tomorrow, I can go
to this other store,
and I don't have to clutter my
screen with the little icons.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right, I see.
And you can even do things also.
You can put a link to
those stories on your home
screen anyway via that website.
ALEX DANILO: That's right.
In fact, we have
installed a home screen.
Chrome has a feature-- in
fact, many mobile browsers
have the same feature-- where
if you visit a site a few times,
the browser goes, hey,
you like this thing.
Would you like me to stick
an icon on your home screen?
And if you say yes, it'll
put a little icon there.
And then from the
user's point of view,
the next time they click on
it, it just looks like an app
to them.
So they can't actually
tell the difference
between an installed
app and just a website.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So browsers
are effectively becoming
more app-like in some ways.
Or sites on browsers.
ALEX DANILO: They are.
In fact, modern
browsers-- like when
you're talking about standards--
I'll just rewind a little bit.
If you run back,
say, 10 years, there
used to be a
standard called WAP.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
OK, I remember WAP.
ALEX DANILO: You remember WAP.
See?
A lot of people remember it.
I won't talk about
some of the quotes
about WAP, not here anyway.
But WAP was a standard,
and it shipped
on a ton of mobile devices.
Like hundreds of thousands.
And even millions, sorry.
So that standard lasted
for quite a while.
But it was really primitive.
It was geared to the
mobile devices of the time.
Fast forward 10 years.
We're in the smartphone era,
where the thing in your pocket
is like a supercomputer
from a long time ago.
And the browser
is full-featured.
It's as powerful as
a desktop browser.
And so the shift to
mobile is not just
a shift into new styles of
browsers with new capabilities,
but the power there
gives you all this stuff
that we didn't have
before, that you usually
associate with native apps.
Like, for example,
accelerometers.
You have the device
orientation API.
So it can flip my phone
around, and actually
play a game with a ball
rolling in my browser.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah, nice.
ALEX DANILO: Another
feature that we
brought into the standards
is the battery API.
So from a web page,
I can actually
detect the status of my battery.
So I can choose to
throttle back if I
know I'm not on the charger,
and stuff like that.
So the capabilities
coming to the browsers
are getting closer what's
available to native app
developers.
But this is all coming
through standards development,
and not through some kind
of proprietary edition.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And I assume, then,
if I'm building according
to those standards,
it's going to run on the browser
on multiple platforms also.
ALEX DANILO: That's right.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So I don't need
to build one app for
Android, one app for iPhone,
and one app, maybe,
for other platforms.
ALEX DANILO: Exactly.
That's the beauty of the web.
You build it one place, and
it runs on all the devices.
No compilation necessary.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Very cool.
Now one of the
things that-- it's
been a few years since I was
a web developer, I'll admit.
But one of the things that,
when I was building the web,
it was like I had to
have standards not just
the back of my mind, but
I had to have standards
at the front of my mind.
But sometimes, it
felt like somebody
was imposing a way of doing
things onto me without being
part of my natural workflow.
Now do we have tools or things
that will help developers
through that, and
help developers
so that they can make the
most of building to standards?
ALEX DANILO: There are
quite a number of tools.
One of the things of
developing the standards
is that we have to build tests.
These days, when we
bring in a new feature,
we have to prove
that it's testable,
and we have to write the tests.
And so part of that
is also the W3.
So you have a site called
validator, [? dot ?] W3.org.
And it's an online
validator, where
you can put your mockup in,
and it will check it for you
and tell you if you're adhering
to the standards, which
at least saves you
time as a developer.
They have a bunch of other
tools that check success.
They also check mobile
sites that will actually
render in different
screen sizes,
and give you the
result so you can see
what your site will look like.
So there are a lot
of things like that.
There's also a community effort
called Test the Web Forward.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh,
Test the Web Forward.
ALEX DANILO: Test
the Web Forward.
So this was started
a few years ago.
And what it is is it's kind
of bringing the developer
community together to multi-day
events where we sit around
and we write tests
for browser features,
specifically testing things that
don't work across the browsers.
So the whole point
of a test is write it
like this works in Safari,
this doesn't work in Chrome,
or something like that.
So these tests are
built. And we've
run them in Paris, I think
in San Francisco, in Tokyo,
in Sydney.
All over the world, right?
And this is kind of
a grassroots effort
to make the browsers
more compatible.
And the more compatible
the browsers become,
the easier your life
is as a developer.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And the easier
life is as a consumer as well.
ALEX DANILO: Absolutely.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So you don't
have any of that differences.
So one of the things,
then, is how about Google?
We do have some developer
websites, right?
ALEX DANILO: We do.
We have web fundamentals,
which contains
a lot of great guidance.
There's quite a lot
of focus on mobile.
What to do for mobile.
But just general web
development stuff.
So there's a lot of
resources like that.
And of course, Google
sends engineers
to all sorts of
standards bodies.
I work with the
Chrome engineers.
Part of my role is not just
working with the HTML committee
and the group doing
the editing, it's also
talking to Chrome engineers
and getting their feedback,
and saying, hey,
guys, this is broken.
Or hey, this would be a
cool feature to implement.
And part of that's a
two-way street, right?
It's not a one-way conversation.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
Well, we're just
about out of time.
That was awesome.
I've learned so much.
And you've convinced me
to look more into the web.
ALEX DANILO: Web is great.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's great.
I know it's great.
But you've convinced me more
looking at web mobile apps
as well, instead of just
building native apps.
So thanks, Alex.
So you have any
questions for me,
if you have any
questions for Alex, just
please leave them
in the comments
below, and be sure to subscribe
to the Google Developers
channel.
Thank you.